the challenge of camouflage body
painting is to make the model disappear
within two hours using nothing but paint
and a brush Johannes gutter from South
Tirol has been a body painter for more
than a decade amit video that for me
body painting is everything it's my
profession my passion really my life my
labor Michael stutter also gives one day
workshops participants pay about 100
euros each he captures this ephemeral
art in photos and sells them as
postcards or posters his best-known
camouflage piece is the Frog here he
painted 5 models to create a single
image he's really come with the
difficulties of camouflage body painting
our first that the whole thing works
only from one vantage point and second
that the body is three-dimensional it's
an artist in camouflage body painting
there is a wide range of ways to make
the models blend seamlessly into the
background italian artist Filippo ioco
works with earth and paint while
Bulgarian artist Bella fallen makes her
model disappear almost completely behind
these lines tungate distal me if you try
to match the colors as precisely as
possible usually by mixing especially
with motifs from nature and you have to
make a three-dimensional body look
two-dimensional for example if you want
the effect of a straight line the one
you paint isn't straight it just looks
straight from the right angle get
artists on so does it from the
thickening clouds karate aisle seat the
world bodypainting festival in Austria
has been presenting the latest trends
and
a world champion title since 1998 the
international panel of judges Awards
prizes in various categories including
painting technique brush and sponge
airbrush and special effects the
tradition of the world bodypainting
festival draws many tourists to approach
ha austria on lake verte more than
20,000 people come to the festival each
year Austrian Alex bomkesh founded the
event eighteen years ago yah and young
age was a young and dedicated tourism
manager basically all I wanted to do was
bring some color to a pretty sleepy
region elodie fallacy negan bring in
every year since 2009 Johanna stutter
has presented a new creation at the
festival in 2012 the Italian was crowned
world champion suppose body painting
festival the world bodypainting festival
is definitely the biggest body painting
event in the world I all the body
painters who come here look forward to
it all year it's such a big platform
such an opportunity for body painters to
display their art nowhere else will you
find as much of this kind of art I skip
nerds so fear from these icons to say in
be here Johannes gutter is entering the
competition again this year too with a
work whose team is playing
the body painting them but they lost or
a championship gets tougher all the time
standards rise every year but I'm trying
to stay close to the top this year more
than 300 teams are competing more than
ever before and Johannes shutter hopes
to win his second World Championship
title